you
hi everybody hi how's it going good good
glad to hear it you can see I got a pile
of boxes here as per usual hello hi hi
everybody
hi hi hi hi hi you hi hi hi been a while
since I just did a live stream for the
sake of live streaming and by a while I
mean back when I had like maybe a
hundred viewers at a time that's the
last time I did so this is kind of new
for me nothing really going on besides
to be opening some mail but this is
actually easier for me as opposed to
anything why Blue Island gamer gets
banned erino ban okay anyway yeah hi
everybody
a looping gif of me bouncing I'm not
bouncing I'm actually not sitting in my
chair this is me standing right now I'm
this tall um you can see that you know
I'm I'm just towering above everything
it's a shuffle off over here and then
shuffle back I'm not sitting cuz it's
just easier if I don't so just waiting
for people to get in here we are
broadcasting in 720p we are so you can
do that or you can downsize to the other
streams it's just a webcam video so it
shouldn't be that bad the bitrate should
never go that high I don't see why high
high high high high high high high high
high five ten I'm not five ten I'm like
I'm like three foot three I'm like
wicked short man I'm like I'm tiny how's
my day busy I've been up since 6:00 so
nine hours I like getting up in the
morning though it makes me feel like I'm
being productive which is hard in my
line of work I hardly ever feel like I'm
being productive but today I actually
did although I only woke up early
because I slept weird my shoulder hurt
everyone feel bad for me my shoulder oh
just ah man twitches ohh
and yes yeah I am back on twitch I am
back on twitch because um apparently it
was not intentional that my twitch
account got banned there was someone
that hacked an admin account on twitch
and started banding random channels
that's why some other channels were
banned around the same time I was so I I
guess they don't hate charity twitch
doesn't hate charity so we're still good
here so we're back okay huh it's a
little happy dance you're gonna actually
do stuff where we're only going to go
about maybe an hour hour and a half see
how long this takes
I'm just waiting for people to get in
here and I've got a little soundtrack of
royalty-free music that I'm totally
allowed to play whenever I feel like it
so I will be here I will be here pretty
soon
it's just easy listening you'll see it
it's pretty it's gonna be pretty quiet
I've got a pretty low volume so yeah if
anything you'll barely hear it just
something to get a little besides the
horse crunch
crumble crumble pop pop pop markiplier
that stuff you know the usual you know
yeah I have ants in my pants I do not I
actually like being on twitch chat
because I can actually read what people
are saying as opposed to on YouTube
where it's a 30-second delay here it's
only like a four second delay if that I
see like four three two one four second
delay I was exactly right
oh I am so genie sometimes do I know I
am awesome possibly maybe I don't know I
can read it I'm a very quick reader I
can read things very quickly
I like 10,000 pages a minute I think I
think the officials number I never got
tested but I'm pretty sure it's around
their next charity is on two weekends
from now or something like that I don't
know sometime I'll figure it out later
how awesome are Pringles I don't really
like Pringles scp-173 behind you oh yeah
ah ah got you someone blinked he's not
supposed to blink anyone who blinked who
blinked alright whatever
Boop put that over there okay now that
people are filtering in enough I'm going
to start opening soon blonde
Dodge forget and don't forget this this
will be put onto YouTube later we put
onto YouTube afterwards so anyone that
misses this can watch it there but you
guys don't need to know that because
you're already here and you're gonna
watch it now but anyone who's not here
and can listen to my voice now it's
going to be on YouTube later so here we
go let's get into it up everyone ready
how about ready let's do it they're
already open I don't know I got this
let's start with a top one and get it
going
it's like Christmas for me I mean I feel
weird sometimes I'm just like everyone
look at me open my presents I'm like
that kid that everyone hated you know in
the neighborhood that he got all the
presents and he bragged about it all the
time I'm just shoving it in everyone's
face what do we got here yeah what is
this oh yeah okay
mark I love your videos and you always
bring a smile to my face I hope that you
like this gift and that you continue to
make a difference thank you for all that
you do
much love Alex and here's the music let
me know if you like it if you don't I
don't care it's good play anyway ha dug
that down ok anyway
to bag what's in the bag a bomb to a
bomb point away from my face so it
doesn't explode all over me hey when
that happens I get this open oh it's a
bowtie okay I know I know what I'm doing
you all just calm down they're doing
this live we're doing it lot Mikey get
the bloody thing over there no way oh my
God look everybody look I've always
wanted one of these with the knife most
likely that would be the best map Oh God
wanted I've seen I've seen people with
these all the time and I've always been
like oh really been like oh my god oh
yes it's an iron one - everyone knows
irons better than diamond by far look at
this thing
oh yeah yeah I am that kid in the
neighborhood that everyone hates look at
the toy I got do you all like my toy
then it is cool it's like it's as Lord
from my craft point in real life
oh I'm gonna smack Wade with it yes I am
I'm gonna run outside start like my
neighbors already think that I'm crazy
cuz I just start screaming randomly at
random times of the day but but I'm
gonna just go outside and start running
down the street like good
well I'm king of Minecraft kinkajou
squirrel yeah okay thank you Alex
thank you so much for that they're
really cool I like that bag data came in
it's just a big burlap bag from Amazon
very very classy
whole areas sectioned off work crap
whoa no wait I'm sorry I'm this tall I
doubt that was a fluke I didn't know I'm
not GLA another one of those French
words read on camera and then there's
another one that says read off camera
will I play facade no no no no
hang on I think you might have been
getting some double bleed from the
headphones around the microphone there
all along okay let's see what this
happens oh my goodness it's a long um
markiplier before any introductions I
would like to start off this by saying
that you what a fantastic individual you
are your impact on this world through
both your entertainment and charity work
is phenomenal and truly inspiring
continue on this path and never stray
and your fans will all back you as you
change the world for the better thank
you so much and there's quite a lot here
I'm gonna just skim over it Kyle of
Tyler Norman 19 year old from West
Virginia as a computer tech in the
counties school different than a fan for
quite some time first video I ever saw
was slender death camp which I stumbled
upon
thanks to my Slenderman addiction I
immediately picked up on your killer
voice along with the fact that you
actually speak like an intellectual
should well I should fix that I always
say that my entertainment is bottom of
the barrel at best but help continue
speaking of which TradeMe voices
sometimes no send me a surgeon simulator
2013 style preferably anyway soon after
showing my friends I subscribed as a
matter of fact you were the first person
I ever subscribed to and I'm almost
positive I was your 150,000 subscriber
as the count was one for 99999 as I
click to subscribe I don't know some
jerkbaits could have been me to it last
second but I'll skim down a little more
I'll read this all later
to end it I just want to say thanks
thank you for all the great walkthroughs
for your wonderful laughs when I'm
feeling worse for your charity work for
inspiration for bringing me closer to my
son my friends and for helping me pass
the time while grinding some of the most
monotonous skills in runescape for being
yourself and truly caring about the
little people out there you're exactly
whatever youtuber needs to be keep it up
man sincerely Tyler Norman well thank
you so much that means a lot to me I try
to make a difference but it's not really
me it's not really sure Abner I'm
reading chat I am reading chat so I'm
really I'm reading what you're saying I
can see what you're saying I can see
everything anyway so thank you so much
let's see what's in the box and there's
a reed off-camera ooh
what's this it's in bubble wrap which
everyone knows I love cool wicked
awesome look at this it's a it's a
Necromorph action figure with stab emic
stabbed stabbed in the eyeball action
it's got super claws
that'll gouge out your guts it's called
it's this is the slasher I didn't even
know that there were dead space action
figures I didn't think that there was
that monetized in terms of toys but
either way that's pretty cool so thank
you so much Tyler that stabbed awesome
action you know you know what I'm
talking about so thank you guys and
thank you I got so much stuff it's
unbelievable some stuff that I keep like
this ah this ah ah hurts it hurts ah
okay I'm a big baby anomic oh that
really did hurt I whacked it good did
you all hear that is it hurt oh okay
anyway ah now it's hard to be on my
knees I mean on my feet cuz I'm standing
what is this this is from a Skilling's
and it is looks like something Xbox II
hello from France hello everybody hello
hello hello you were away for five
seconds
well you haven't missed much oh it's a
it's an Xbox 360 headset with keyboard
keyboard at the same time I don't have
Xbox Live but if I ever do if I ever do
I will use this I promise you that if I
ever get Xbox Live I will use this so
thank you so much I've always wanted a
keyboard for that I always hated using
the gamepad to get the things one things
like computer the PC master-race is
always gonna be better
so our desk is okay I'm just kidding
thank you so much it wasn't a notary
think so oh yes there was hang on
there's a note here let me get to it
hello Xbox sucks
market bar I'm a huge fan of your
channel which I discovered just a few
weeks ago like so many others I found it
when life was at its worst your
Slenderman videos brought a broad smile
to my face when nothing else could
inside the package is an Xbox mark from
which you may give away if you desire in
my hopes that you open this on camera I
was hoping you could do a shout out for
me by reading the following out loud to
all my friends at school thank you for
the support - Kim G I have warm
friendship feelings towards you and help
things between us and that's not from me
okay - Kim G Andrew loves you and hopes
things between you two improves good
luck the biggest thanks goes to you mark
bar for making me laugh until my stomach
hurts
best of wishes and I hope your channel
prospers Andrew s PS you've just endured
the terrible handwriting of a lefty hope
you were able to read it all so good
luck to you and hopefully Kim sees this
declaration of love and goes running
back into your arms so thank you so much
good luck to you hope everything works
out Dada
I look like the Team Fortress 2 medic
I've gotten that a lot I'm not a
successful procedure haha yeah I got
moving on moving on into the next pitch
ah whoa what is this yeah let's see here
there's another there's more must expand
business I actually there's this is the
same moustache bandage that is this one
right here so see I do keep the things
right here within arm's reach so thank
you so much for that but there's more
stuff in here there's a Dragonball Z
postcard so let me read this dear
markiplier I know you will read this in
like every letter but I wanted to say
thank you for being absolutely awesome I
love the way you entertain us fans and
how you help the world with your L
streams J please stay awesome
kisses but only in a friendly manner
Nina H from Switzerland sorry I couldn't
get another card hope you like it though
feel free to give away whatever you
and as soon as I know someone is from
another country I must speak in their
native language I like Dragon Ball Z I
watched it when I was child on Toonami -
thank you so much there is also more
Swiss chocolate chocolate from
Switzerland it looks like oh that's
pretty cool it is drink savers ice cube
trade that is I'm done with that I'm
moving on to something different than
Swiss I don't even know what that was I
was oh even know they look like a
lifesaver like raft things you know you
throw some ones overboard you throw to
them they look sad but you're playing a
drink that's cool all right that's there
I'll put the chocolate down there for
later
underneath my magic desk here let's see
and a little bitty is that edible I
don't think this is edible I'm gonna eat
it anyway and oh these are these are
edible mustaches these are edible
mustard oh no they're not
oh they're molds they're molds for like
cookies but I don't bake so I'll do what
best I can
I remember I had to sign for this
package specifically from Switzerland so
sweeter Lindh from Switzerland okay
anyway I'm gonna eat everything that
gets sent to me just because it's
starting to clutter up my apartment I'm
gonna just eat stuff oh and you know you
know it'll go to a good cause like my
traning but Italy okay
alright one with the monkey on the box
looks very bomb like but it's a box
within a box which I do not appreciate
I'm guess I'm gonna get so fat high from
Indianapolis I can still read this hi
from Venezuela
- I'm Venezuela Venezuelan stalk like
these if you didn't know and if you
didn't know I make fun of everybody
that's why it's okay hi from South
Carolina actually everyone in the world
is gonna talk like this hello I am from
anywhere in the world
name is Jurgen stark and I am what is
this oh it's an aperture laboratories
water bottle cool not Swedish penis pump
oh look at that I hope I've been using
my my Batman goblet here for water for a
while there so I do appreciate an actual
water bottle which is awfully nice so
thank you for that who is wrong I think
there's a note this is directly from oh
here we go hi mark thank you for being
who you are and doing what you do when
I'm feeling down i watch your videos and
can't stop smiling can't wait for the
next live stream well it's right now so
hello Slovene yeah I don't think
Sylvania is a real place I don't think
so I from Texas Florida Denmark area you
don't need to say where you're from I
don't care I don't care hahaha
markiplier doesn't care hashtag
markiplier is careless bastard oh okay
don't say that I care I don't care I
care do I care
you'll never know you're too confused to
know silliness this is a serious serious
event oh by the way I'm wearing this
shirt that someone sent me I survived
Slenderman how about that I've been
wearing it in public no one has said
anything either they think I'm weird or
they don't like my shirt or they don't
know about Slenderman what does no one's
letterman what sorry bet okay yeah cuz
it was a heavy one this is from Robbie
Linden
i nicaragua everyone from nicaragua talk
like that what do we got here some games
oh my god uh-huh oh it stinks a bit bit
dusty but yeah this is a kind of this is
a PlayStation 2 someone sent me a
PlayStation 2 I'm not gonna pull it out
of there I just cuz dog Lee dusty and I
just inhaled a bunch of it cuz it's
obviously wolf but there's actually some
a bunch of 360 games in here I mean like
a lot XCOM fox 2 left 4 dead I guess
someone's trying to convert me away from
the glorious PC gaming master race which
will never happen but I do appreciate
the gesture there's Dragon Age Ultimate
Edition year 3 a perfect dark seer I
didn't think they remade this but
apparently they did big bumpin I don't
know what that means
I think it's a bumper car game but yeah
and then there's places go so holy crap
there's a lot of stuff oh man I do not
deserve that smash stuff you guys are
ridiculous with the gift so I mean thank
you so much that's that's crazy I hope
it didn't get damaged on the way there I
mean it's there's not much packaging in
this box it was awfully heavy so I hope
it still works thank you so much that's
it's absolutely incredible I didn't see
a note in there so I guess I was it but
wow I mean I'm not this tall I'm this
tall you didn't see anything I'm short
I'm short in real life I didn't cut this
one open oh yes I do okay this one is
from Aaron II buyers buyers buyers
there's a purse which I need it for my
dress mom mom no ha ha it's a purse with
in a purse with in a purse with nothing
in it someone's a troll okay then
there's I don't know what this is but
it's kind of awesome it's like a little
bear with a squishy ball head that's
cool
let us say you rock I do look at me
I'm amazing okay thank you so much uh
also a bag with bomb no bomb careful
with the painting it was done in oil
pastel there's a painting of Slenderman
with a mustache I'm pretty sure and then
there's something else in here
oh the Slenderman song I'm apparently
supposed to sting this hmm you get a
special treat guys you actually get to
sorry I sped again but you get a special
treat you get to hear me sing over the
music that's playing currently so mm-hmm
Slenderman Slenderman all the children
try to run Slenderman Slenderman
to him
it is part of the fun but Oh Canada all
right enough of that
Stosh up ever shut up I'm a good singer
you all don't know I'm gonna be on
American Idol you all better vote for me
that's all I have to say about that
thank you so much
no oh you didn't like it oh good good
fine whatever I don't need your approval
I'm mark Pryor I Know Who I am I know
what's best I my voice is what bet I am
incredible to hear maybe if I was
singing it Swedish would have been more
adventure but they don't they took all
the hard what they don't okay
this box of cheese's is from my little
brother Christian he told me to tell you
that quote you Mark Fischbach will
always be a sexy man no matter how many
boxes of cheez-its you eat or how many
cookies you non on you will always be
are markiplier we love you take care so
thank you for the box and there's
actually quite a few things in here it's
a bunch of pixel bead art really well
done there's a mustache hahaha wow
that's a pretty good montage and then
that looks like a gameboy a little
gameboy on a keychain there
Oh first off there's I don't know what
that is oh it's a fox oh okay I didn't
see it till I put it into the camera my
dog Fox really well done and there's a
there's a book with a lot of looks like
breast cancer support stuff so maybe
this person is a breast cancer survivor
okay you're probably wondering what the
hell that it is you were holding this is
my letter to you I'm sure you've gotten
a lot of time letters and handwritten
but have you ever gotten a scrap letter
I think not and with that let's begin
first off I want to thank you for the
live streams of your donation to all the
different cancer research centers my
grandmother no excuse me my grandmother
sadly passed away a few years ago due to
cervical and breast cancer I'll get a
phone call shop I don't have time for
you job Wade job I'm doing a live drain
okay but it's people like you who give
me hope thank you and then there's a
bunch of other pages with some scrap
things from my I'll read I'll go through
this later but there's like slender
stuff slandered Christmas special the
gray work and when I said fettuccine
alfredo somewhere in there I didn't
remember saying that at all but
apparently I did so that's in there
happy wheels gotta bring back worse -
and death and dead space with duh I
might look okay so thank you guys so
much you guys
I've been amazing I really do appreciate
that there's actually even more stuff in
here this is quite an involved box
there's another Game Boy with a
Minecraft whoops there's a mine it fell
off a Minecraft block of dirt grass
block whatever you want to call it
that's there there's a lot of stuff I
got to keep it all organized so if I'm
gonna lose it then there's a blanket in
here I don't know if it's just a blanket
or if it's covering so no it's just a
blanket it's a blanket let's see if
there's something on it it is what is
that Superman Superman good I've
actually I've actually not been in a big
into a lot of comic book super
superheroes in a while but I am looking
forward to the the new Superman movie
that's
going to come out soon Man of Steel
hopefully that's gonna be good it looks
good I mean it's about time that they
showed the human side of Superman even
though he's not I know he's got I know
I'm not human
I'm not II I know he's not Ashley I need
Kryptonian I'm sweating okay I got
microfiber glove but dab up my sweat
it's hot in here I don't know why why
isn't my air conditioning on my hair how
am i beautiful hair it's gonna be it's
all anyway you saw my undies yet there
you want me to take my pants off no
let's get nothing yeah that's it okay
moving on we got another one here just
look at my amazing physique for a minute
oh it's a box within a box Kersh turn it
you guys are killing me with these
things I'm gonna go insane box within a
box within a box within a troll within a
box within another box unboxing
okay all right what have we got here
what is this box it what what
haha
like the Horsehead mask except it's a
pigeon I think it's a pigeon I even know
what this is it's horrifying I can't
have this in my my apartment it'll scare
the crap out of me oh it's a pigeon mask
yeah it's a pigeon mascot man thank you
for that whoever said that and I don't
know what was on that but I'd burn my
eyes
no no dancer actor oh man
anyway hope you all enjoyed that a
little bit there oh yeah my okay anyway
so please use that on a vid that's hard
enough to get on and off it smells bad
but anyway thank you for whoever gave
that I didn't see a name or a note
anywhere but you know who you are so
thank you it's from Amazon so alright
okay am I looking am i looking good
about it my hair my hair got the natural
wave to it I'm uh I'm so I'm so handsome
oh my god I'm just oh okay
this one's shaky what's in here ah
thumb in my eye ah tell me in my eye
sorry thumb in my eye
oh okay you want that mask Oh bye it's
barely on Amazon you're fabulous Marc
don't worry thank you so much
oh my goody gumdrops and I know I know I
know yeah everybody chat shirt off cuz
that I bow down to peer pressure like a
twig see here we got something I think
this might just be a spacer but I is
just packaging material I'm like look at
this wow it wore God is amazing Oh
someone ha ha ha this is what happens
this is what happens
I carry mentioned
oh hey I like nerds and never goes give
them nerds give them and then and then I
say you know I once I said oh I really
like Jesus I'll use a box Jesus of the
halo chains it's more than life itself
let's give them all the cheese's in the
world ha ha I'm just joking I like nerds
but six boxes imma get so back I'm gonna
eat all of them
everyone's still other shirt off thing
there's not gonna happen ladies and guys
out there I know it's you I know who you
are
not gonna be there all mine my church
I'm gonna put another shirt on
that's what I'm gonna do and it's not
even gonna be a Slenderman streak it's
gonna be a crappy shirt you know one
that you aren't gonna like it's it's all
all this is what you get oh is what you
get I'm wearing American Eagle now what
you wanted this I bet you didn't and now
this is what you get this is what
happens
waiting without me yes no I don't want
to do you see you want this I don't even
want this yeah I took my shirt off what
happening still looking
I know haha double shirt and pigeon mask
no be good there's also freezable fruit
thingies in here so thank you for that
in a bag of oregano this is not weed I
can tell by the the herbs that are in
here this is oregano so thank you for
that I guess and that is from I don't
know who that's from but thank you so
much
alright next my knees are killing me
what do we got a bomb
yes oh yeah Gor my sir flasks a gig or
Meister insulated flask mmm it's a green
here this please I need some alcohol to
get through this no that empty it's
empty but I will feel it later thank you
so much for this it's really cool it's
really well made it's like a smooth
finish and everything oh yeah thank you
guys so much this really awesome gifts
have been played more than I deserve
like I said before thank you from that's
from tee dang tee dang no no so thank
you again you know who you are and thank
you use it for drunk minecraft that's a
good idea thank you
who did that who did that DJ man 10
thank you that was a really good idea I
really appreciate your input I I sound
angry but I sound angry when I'm
actually grateful so don't be upset I'm
just kidding
I'm messing with you no one knows what I
really think
so much Moscow I know you all are
impressed by my amazing marvelous oh
it's a handlebar wine opener Oh
handlebar moustache
oh really look and then there are
mustache ice cube trays yeah I love ice
cube trays I don't know why I never knew
that I really liked them but they're
pretty awesome so thank you guys so much
haha show them gone yeah everybody like
like that yeah okay yeah I know I know
I'm amazing
let me just yeah thank you so much for
waking up it was it's from Caroline a
nipple who has given me stuff before my
sister's wanted to give you something if
the other items don't come with this one
then it's to mustache ice cube trays and
a housewarming gift we hope you like
them from Carolyn Silvana and Rachelle
thank you so much that's awesome
I really do appreciate why am I so sexy
years of intense physical training years
and years aids get this all of this
oh yeah
more cookies more cookies more cookies
I'll not get so fat I've literally I've
been trying to buy healthy foods you
know and you guys are just piling it on
with the cookies and the candy and
cheez-its I got nothin I gotta eat it
you know there are starving kids in
Africa so hey hi Billy Bob my Billy Bob
you got banned so thank you for that
hang on I gotta open the big giant card
let's see it
hold on hmmm congratulations on hitting
three hundred thousand subscribers and
for hosting this month charity
livestream thank you for again for your
generosity and kindness for others and
for starting season two of drunk
minecraft please give Bob and Wade a
package of cookies if it is pause thanks
again Serena
and by the way drunk minecraft will be
um we've had some technical difficulties
Bob and Wade were dumb and they recorded
their cameras wrongly so I have to fix
them manually
I'm very angry at both of them but
anyway it should be coming probably by
tomorrow
and speaking of subscribers like it was
crazy yesterday I mean it was just
absolutely insane because we got I
believe six thousand subscribers
yesterday like 6000 subscribers who's
actually unbelievable it was the most
subscribers we've ever gotten in a
single day so thank you guys so much I
mean I think Yami and I shout to do with
it because with our collaborating to see
that many people join it once and I
couldn't even wrap my head around it
because I remember what I was like oh I
got 20 subscribers in a day this is
awesome and now it's been 6,000 in a
day's ridiculous is like - it's crazy so
anyway so thank you guys so much alright
okay cookies go over again so anyway we
are actually whittling them down pretty
quickly we what do you mean we how do I
say how do I say we what do I say it
weird do I say weird we weird you guys
you guys need to know this the way I say
room I say room that is the correct way
you say room you push a broom not a
broom you you go in the room you push a
broom in the room we can drink rum
that's not rum it's rum it's not ROM its
room ha ha ha you guys you guys are all
wrong it's a correct pronunciation
you've been doing it wrong all your life
you're wrong I'm right get over it
it's so correct rum rum rum rum rum rum
rum rum rum rum rum rum it room toppling
over all day I'm still right I'm still
right I don't know uh well oh look at
that that's not all there's things in
the back bed sorry I didn't know the
thing it was the back of it hang on okay
okay all right here we go
I know this sounds weird and like a
really dumb lie but I really want to
thank you it's because of you that my
life is a whole lot better I'm not
saying that my life was all super
depressing before I watched all of your
videos it's just that I'm a total loser
at my school with not a lot of friends I
have to well one of them used to be just
an acquaintance kinda but one day she
invited me to her house just to visit
we ended up watching one of your horror
compilations on YouTube and just thought
that you were the funniest guy ever
we became huge fans right there so after
then I would go to her house all the
time and we would just watch as many
videos of yours if we could this made my
day every day because I spent so much
time over at your house we found a lot
of things in common we had the same
likes and classes anime books and a
whole lot of other stuff she even
invited me to go to a convention
Milwaukee with her I always joke that
I'm at her house more than my own and no
matter how many times did I been at her
house we'd never fail to watch your
videos now I'm happy to wake up in the
morning just knowing I'll see my friend
and then go out then go to her house to
watch markiplier during one of your last
jeans my friend donated 10 bucks and you
actually said her name she called me so
excitedly that I was afraid she might
have a heart attack but just knowing
that made my day knowing she was happy I
just want to say thank you mark thanks
so much for making my Latin me laugh
until my sides hurt and thank you so so
much for helping me find my best friend
Dana
sincerely Gary Gerber's Jerry Gary
probably not Gary Jerry Gruber's keep
doing what you're doing you're the best
and mine and Dana's hero so thank you
guys so much thanks for a letter I'm
glad that I could make an impact in your
life there's more fan art right here me
and a ballerinas does that mean yeah no
that's not me that's got blonde hair
there no that's me it's a blonde hair
no it's blonde wings on a thing so
that's what that's me that's me of the
ballerina look pretty good
I probably good pretty good ballerina
good not doing my super ballet you know
all that stuff so thank you guys so much
for this and the painting which if you
guys missed go go giant moustache oh oh
okay thank you guys so much for that I
really appreciate that I could bring you
guys together I mean that that's some
special oh there's one more
whoa whoa John Canty
go you thank you all right over
here
oh my god it's a maze all right what
have we got here
Oh see my dress my dress is in my closet
we have cookies gingerbread cookies mmm
those smell good I might have one of
those later that smells delicious
and there's something else oh wait no
hang on there's a letter first um
dearest mark enclosed in this package
you will find two things homemade
cookies and a handmade minion there's a
chair that we made for you regarding the
cookies we know that you're just going
to say you'll get fat but these are
healthy cookies they are made with
yogurt applesauce and wheat flour and a
heaping spoonful of love we know they
sound weird but they are pretty darn
good and in the mini chair is 100%
handmade with balsa wood and plenty of
super glue so now you'll always have a
way to protect yourself from any raging
fangirls that might want to nibble your
giblets totally not like us
so enjoy your gifts and keep doing what
you're doing cuz even if you don't know
it you're helping a lot of people and
also because you're so smart and brave
and hantum that was actually in there I
didn't just add that flinch nearly your
friends Melissa and Susan so thank you
so much
and all you fangirls that want to nibble
on my giblets and want me to dig out my
shirt no siree Bob I save it for
marriage No
and there's also this mustache oh wait
where's the chair oh no here here that's
from the last one I think that mustache
is from the painting hmm
God touch packaging
why why why why would you do this to me
why I'm still unwrapping it I had to rip
it I rip it
oh look at that see pretty nice that
looks exactly like an amnesia chair look
at that that's really well done that's
really amazingly well done good job on
that back off I got a chair back off
everybody back off fan girls back off I
got a chair ah okay thank you so much
for that I'm gonna set that right there
for safekeeping all right let's see here
dude
oh this one's gotta be rip oh this one's
the bomb Eunice the chairs no I
absolutely do not need to do more chair
of idios house just a silly thing I did
a few times back when I didn't know what
I was doing
oh my god you're kidding me are you
kidding me with this for that why didn't
you just send the box ah guys are
killing me
what up Zack Rhys what up what up
oh you got band problem hey Mark did you
like your box if not look under the box
I hope you will like the instat month
the money
Yuki can you donate our keep and yes I'm
going to make you so fat but keep making
videos the way you are making them it
works from general GAC on YouTube GAC
general
you know what I totally believe there's
money in here
definitely Oh without a doubt in my mind
oh yeah they're definitely in here haha
yeah oh yeah there's um uh money
I guess mom Chu I don't even know what
that is
that was mope oh wait hang on there's
there's one Denmark auguste involved in
it's worth 20 Krone or kroner 20 kronor
that's like I don't know but probably
like 5 cents I don't know why do I put
up with you guys all right next
okay here's the one with the mustache
tape that someone else was talking about
there isn't one to Medford here oh uh
badoo badoo badoo badoo badoo um dear
markiplier firstly let me just say that
I'm perfectly okay with you skipping
over this box in your fan mail video
secondly you're free to give away any of
these gifts it's entirely up to you I've
only recently begun watching your videos
but I'm already a fan although I do have
a small crush on you and I'm a girl I
don't consider myself a fangirl meaning
if I saw you walking down the street I
wouldn't Maul you and tear your clothes
off or would I yeah you probably would
anyway I'm a gamer myself and have a
youtube channel that I would learn one
day like to fill with Let's Plays I
really admire that you use your fame and
comedic talents comedic talents to raise
money for charities and that you're so
connected with your fans please keep
doing exactly what you're doing less
than 3 Jayma doodle at the bottom of the
nevermind I can't read that part hahaha
sorry sorry everybody
had to cut that one short the mystery
will always remain there's um I just
Nick it's a little sticky look a little
okay it shall forever remain a mystery
there's a shot-glass that says I heart
zombies I'm not gonna open it because
it's pain and there's something else in
here there's what is this
Carman ated drink late lemonade flavor
too carbonated lemonade flavored drink
from Japan I think I'm not sure but cool
I think that's Japan maybe that's China
I'm not sure I can't tell I'm half
Korean and I don't know
so anyway is this any good is it
I've now I'll try it later so anywho I
don't know what the hell I'm getting
there's also another shot gasps that
says one tequila two tequila three
tequila floor
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha oh ok I can
read what was on the letter now I had to
cut it short because I knew is gonna be
something troll esque um this is what
the letter said PS at the bottom of this
box is a very lewd picture of myself if
you do open this on camera for the sake
of your younger viewers please look
discreetly you guys guys ready you want
we'll see you oh it's good uh still hot
it says uh sure her hair both i troll
you owe more troll box of God am i doing
with my life
what am i doin my life okay oh my knees
are killing me
my knees are being destroyed by this
haha yeah epic troll haha i troll you
haha
you mad bro oh man you so jelly let's
see what's in here
hey you know Barney well bird look who
do you - Barney and hey it's a little
crunchy
and also there is a wouldn't let her
hello mark read this privately please
okay reading privately and put that over
there read these publicly okay for Bob
and Wade who for Bob and Wade Bobby
we've got something finally to mark well
they're not finally I've gotten stuff
before I remember let's see oh thank you
for being such an inspiration
Tom one to look forward to someone to
laugh with and most of all someone who
makes me smile
you truly are worth everything you
receive I'm so happy you exist
Natasha PS you can hang the slender
chain it's not meant to be worn slender
G wear uh-huh this little is a little
box here with oh this is for Bob and
Wade look look everybody look it's a
little B it's a beer mug it's a little
beer mug in there's a little W that's so
cool looks like the chain fell off at
that one but it'll get back on later but
that's so cool thank you
I'm sure they'll love that I'll give
them over here so they can get it
I'm sorry I don't see I'll find it later
though so I'll find it later and I'll
read this later so click that over there
so thank you people talking bad about me
on chatting I can see what you're saying
behave yourself okay few more we've
managed to whittle down the pile pretty
quickly I mean how long have we been
going for not long right I can see it's
a box within an envelope
what's in the box what's in the box
Oh jack box a deck of what a deck of
cards what kind of cards a deck of Honor
these what are these
I've never seen these before what art
what is that I don't know what this is
some side of the Dragons and I don't
know what this is I've never seen this
ravenous dragon - dragon mega Rex pack
dragon tiny Rex vacuum Manas ha ha look
it's a vacuum mammoth let's see
Oh van guard it says on the back ok I
can't there couldn't see the back cuz
they're all just green I've never heard
of this before in my life no they're not
magic cards they just uh Vanguard cards
I've never heard of Vanguard before then
again I haven't kept up with games a
while let me read the note that's with
it here uh-huh
um hi I don't really know what to say
yeah my name is David and I have been
subscribed since 50k I love all your
videos and I think you're hilarious I
especially love drunk minecraft in your
slender videos I was bullied severely to
the point people tried to kill me oh my
god I was only 13 I had to be removed
from public school and lost contact with
most of my friends now the things I can
look forward to are your videos and
Saturdays for the one day I can actually
get out of the house in a week because I
am now homeschooled thank you all thank
for all you do never stop making videos
read off-camera okay
alright so I'll read the rest off-camera
but now that that's horrible that's
horrible it actually is something that
happens a lot more than people like to
people like to admit and it's a damn
shame I hope you're doing better now
because that's that's sad I'm sorry
about that I feel I feel bad now that's
awful
okay alright um I really do hope things
get better for you so please please stay
strong I know you're still young but
anything can change ah oh when I was a
kid I didn't have many friends you know
I didn't have any friends at all because
I started from a private school and I
moved to public school all my teachers
hated me for some reason and I was going
through my parents divorce at the time
and it was just it was really rough so
but things got better you know I found
people that I agreed with so whatever
you do just stick with it you know
things can always be better if you try
to improve yourself and you know just
improve yourself in general um don't
wait for something to happen go out in
there and try to make it better as soon
as you can because even though it seems
hopeless you know you're still got a
long life Eddie alright just stick with
again Thanks
next one
probably a poster of some sort give it a
go yep we got here bump oh thank you hmm
and oh baby how you do that is that is
creepy
ha ha ha that is freaky I just saw that
for some reason that's like the
freakiest thing on there well that in my
face up in the top corner something
going on with my buddy my nothing but
you know it thank you so much who is
this from
I don't see a name um from a with row a
with a row so thank you guys so much for
that thank you a with a row oh dear for
Thea keeping just do a few more
everyone liking the view okay yeah - oh
yeah I know
dead here yeah oh okay all right
oh behind me am i behind one second
there's more bubble wrapping you all
know how much I live bubble wrap
oh my goodness I'm trying not to damage
it I'm trying to be as careful as
possible it's a painting if you haven't
gathered oh oh it's a collage it's a
collage of different screen caps with me
Bob and Wade that's really cool check it
out
that's amazing that's a lot of stuff
thank you for that I'm not love doing
live shows BOM we even though they
screwed up I still love them so anyway
don't
uh-huh and there's a note on the back in
Japanese I think it said cute Slendy
looky doom look at him what did you do
my kid here he get you okay there is one
two note mmm - mark you are amazing at
what you do especially raising money for
charity I'm sure that you've heard these
kinds of things so many times from other
people but it just shows how much we
appreciate and support you making us
laugh together with Bob and Wade thank
you
please keep playing games making Vee
logs raising money for charity
your fans are always right behind you
literally lol this collage is called the
many faces of BMW Bob Wade and Mark or
barb mark and Wade yeah I go before Wade
yeah
see you in the next video bye bye from
Priscilla de NOLA my brother says my
brother James says hi it's my birthday
on May 1st turning 15 so happy birthday
thank you right let's just do one more
here
do this one whoop
bat yeah Oh smells nice there's a lot of
stuff in here see designer pushpins to
murder me in my sleep
um designer flowers to murder me in my
sleep some sort of rose
Oh rose frigates that's why it smelled
nice it's rose fragrance to murder me in
my sleep and there's juicy fruit
fragrance is gonna make my whole bourbon
smell well there's all types of stuff
there's marine blue and berry and then
there's a bag the bag with nothing in it
so a bag and here we go Oh read this
first oh whoops
hop
get out of there don't rip the thing
uh-huh hey Mark I hope you like what I
got you last time I was the one who sent
you the little piggy charm plush the
cellophane wrapped in the Hawaiian charm
bracelet with a little palm tree
I'm sending you just a bit more stuff
you would hopefully like if for any
reason you have no use for any
particular item you can give it away
anyway I'm still loving your videos and
as I said your videos always make me
smile anyway I hope you liked what I got
you enjoy
sincerely PS I might be able to send
you a few more things in the future so
thank you so much and thank you guys so
much for joining me here for this mail
opening livestream I'm going to stop
here if we've gotten pretty much into
only letter territory now which I read
on my own later so hope you enjoyed it
so far
mark lives alone gotta stuff this in
here there's something important though
that I gotta say before we cut this out
and you're not gonna like it I know that
you guys aren't gonna like it um
basically what has to happen is these
markiplier mail videos are eventually
gonna come to an end
pretty soon the reason being the reason
being I get far too much stuff that
that's just one and that is a bad thing
because I'm going to start I'm going to
keep growing as a channel I'm going to
keep growing as a channel eventually and
this is not going to stop because people
really enjoy getting their boxes on
video and that's all well and good but I
can't do it with everyone if they keep
growing because the pile has been going
exponentially bigger they exponentially
bigger every single time and it's
something that is eating up so much of
my time personally that I can't work on
other projects because I literally am
backlogged for about two days
letters I literally have to sit around
and reload because I read everything
given to me so I have to eventually
close it down so I'm thinking there's
going to be three more of these videos
there's going to be three more of these
videos just to make sure that everyone
who really wanted to get something on
camera will be able to do so I seriously
but I honestly wish that I could and I'm
not ungrateful in any way I am totally
honored that everyone is sending me some
stuff but at the same time I don't
deserve this stuff people are spending
so much money on giving me things that I
don't need and I'm saying I don't need
as in I don't like them I'm saying I
don't need it as in I shouldn't get them
I would rather I would much rather
people use that money and spend it on
the charity livestreams so try to give
it to those who need something good and
I but but but that doesn't mean that you
can't send me stuff you can't that
doesn't mean that you won't be able to
send me stuff the PIO box will still be
there and anything I get will be opened
it just can't be done on camera because
that is encouraging a more and more
people just to send stuff just to be on
camera and I want if people does send me
something I want it to be just for the
sake of them giving me something that
they really feel like and I still want
to have that Avenue open you know I
really do want to have that Avenue open
because I really do care about the
connection that I have with fans but the
kind of I kind of took the wrong
approach with all of this anyway because
instead of just taking a select few I
thought that taking a select few would
be rude to all so I tried to give
everyone a chance and it's just causing
this an avalanche of increasing number
of boxes that is just kind of destroying
my life at the moment and I've got so
much stuff in my apartment now my
one-bedroom apartment now that
eventually if I keep receiving stuff I'm
going to have to throw stuff out or
donate it to charity because I literally
cannot keep it here so anyway um that
doesn't mean that if you send me
something really cool it won't show up
either what I'm just saying you can
still send me stuff the address will
never go away the PIO box is still going
be there you can still send me anything
you want it just will not be on a
markiplier video because I can't keep up
with it anymore and it's down the road
it's going to be on in today's if I have
a million subscribers imagine how many
packages I'll have so if you want to
send me something please do I'm more
than happy to receipt it I still read
every single letter that I get I just
kind of want it to go down and shelf
keep going up so anyway so thank you
guys so much and remember if you do send
me something that doesn't mean it won't
turn up in a live stream like seriously
this is hilarious this would be great on
a live stream and also um the reason I
want more time is because I've got other
things that I'm working on in in the
future you guys remember back in
November when you and helped me and Wade
raise some money for a certain sketch
comedy thing well can't say any
specifics now but you know oh yeah keep
that on the DL but yeah seriously I'm
going to need a lot more time because
I've got about a thousand more projects
that I'm working as I'm growing as a
channel I've got a lot of different
things that I'm going to be working on
and a lot different people that I'm
going to be working on so I need as much
time as possible to be able to do that
so I hope you guys understand and I hope
you guys aren't too terribly upset with
me I know I know this is going to be
very unpopular for some people I know it
is but there's gonna be is still gonna
be three more episodes so if you really
really want to get something to me and
want it to be on camera get it to me
within the next three weeks and it will
be on the live stream like this like
this there will be another live stream
on Monday for the next three weeks where
I will open everything that you give me
again and you will still be able to do
it so is that okay is everyone is
everyone acceptable I know it's not good
news but it's okay news is everyone okay
okay alright still you want hug look I'm
sorry but ugh hug
Oh God
okay Oh work yo another hug okay okay
all right so seriously thank you guys so
much for everything you done you guys
really are I mean I'm I'm the luckiest
guy in the world to have the greatest
fans that you do I mean how many other
youtubers do you see that have the
problem of getting too much stuff that
is ridiculous you guys are so good to me
and I don't even understand why so I
really I really do appreciate everything
you feel violated shut up it was just a
hug like a good hug dough so seriously I
I really do appreciate what you guys
have done for me because you you guys
really have changed my life you know you
see this studio panel soundproofing
stuff you know the only reason I'm able
to get this stuff for what I'm doing is
because I'm I'm dedicating myself 100%
of YouTube now and that's why I'm doing
other stuff too and and I really I'm
really glad that I'm able to move
forward like this I'm I'm actually
hoping to next the next charity
livestream to have it even more
professional than it was before
professional I say kind kind yeah it'll
be better anyway more funny maybe I
don't know but either way so seriously
thank you guys from the bottom of my
heart I I do I didn't want people to
know that I really care about what we've
built here because we built something
incredible something beyond incredible
it's gonna be gonna make a mark on
everyone because we're already inspiring
people to do more stuff to help others
and I'm I'm so proud of what you guys
have done to step off and no I'm not
going to take my shirt off in and then
seriously though thank you guys so much
and I am going to cut this right knob
right cry I'm gonna cut this if you
didn't see if someone didn't get to see
this video it will be on YouTube but I'm
telling you guys again it doesn't matter
you already saw it so you don't know if
you missed any part of it earlier it
will be on YouTube in a matter of an
hour or so so check for it there thank
you guys so much again thank you
everything one more hug one more hug
okay one more shirtless hug no no thank
you thank you everybody okay thank you
thank you
hmm hi bye-bye
so thank you really so much for watching
thank you again everybody and get your
boxes in if you want it on camera you
got three weeks to do it so thanks again
everybody have a good day more videos
tomorrow drunk minecraft coming out so
see you in the next video bye bye bye
bye bye